we want to take a second now to talk
about why this election matters you've
got one more day to vote and if you
haven't there are a lot of reasons you
should that go beyond close races and
who controls Congress if you're angry
you can vent your spleen if you're
positive you can cast a vote for hope
president says vote as if he's on the
ballot so you can show him how you feel
if your locally minded there are six
thousand elections taking place that
won't send anyone to Washington but will
affect your community
155 referenda will affect everything
from abortion rights to whether more
poor people will have access to health
care every vote is a signal and even if
your side loses the size of the losing
vote makes politicians listen if the
vote against them gets bigger they might
be out of a job about even for the loser
might encourage candidates who share
your views to run or spark people of
like mine to band together to push for
other kinds of changes in their
community you're tired of the pundits
the Twitter jockeys Russian hackers and
interest groups that try to think for
you a vote is a chance to bonk them all
in the nose
metaphorically because another reason to
vote is that we want to reaffirm the
original American experiment that we
could resolve our differences through
ballots and not brawls I'll tell you why
I vote just before I was born
people where people were killed trying
to protect the right to vote for black
Americans when intimidation didn't work
voters were made to take poll tests the
questions were designed to confuse one
was spelled backwards forwards another
print the word vote upside down but in
correct order citizens had 10 minutes
and if they didn't make a perfect score
they weren't allowed to vote
fellow Americans were not just denied
they're guaranteed right they were made
to feel small we're all bigger than that
so we don't dare treat that right
lightly it's such a good reminder John
I'm glad you did that because it's such
a good reminder on how important it is
for everybody to vote even when you
think oh it's not gonna make a
difference it always does make a
difference you sort of went step by step
by how it does even if you don't win it
makes a difference and even outside of
our own country there were people all
over the world who are fighting and
dying to try to get the vote to express
their
try to get the right to express their
selves through their vote and as you
point out who have fought and died so
that you have the right to vote I never
take that lightly